[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di voi ascoltano musica sulle
mani bene quanti di voi
suonano o hanno mai suonato uno
strumento bene quanti di voi hanno
suonato in un'orchestra e magari anche
in un teatro vedete già da questo veloce
sondaggio possiamo notare che nonostante
la musica sia un interesse di molti la
pratica musicale strumentale e nello
specifico orchestrale sembra essere
osservata a poche persone quelle che
decidono volontariamente e
consapevolmente di intraprendere un
percorso musicale parallelo
all'istruzione scolastica o quelle
provenienti da famiglie già inserite
nell'ambiente musicale o abbastanza
ambiente da garantire ai propri figli
ogni tipo di educazione e formazione
possibile
eppure è all'interno della scuola che un
bambino dovrebbe scoprire le proprie
potenzialità e i propri talenti
a prescindere da qualsiasi famiglia o
contesto sociale provenga sarebbe
un'utopia vedere arrivare a scuola nella
scuola pubblica bambini e ragazzi con lo
zaino sulle spalle ed in mano la
custodia di un violino o di un corno e
se vi dicessi che tutto questo non solo
è possibile ma è già realtà vedete non
sto parlando dell'ultimo avanguardia nel
campo dell'istruzione nel centro di
qualche grande capitale europea
mi riferisco ad un piccolo comune della
campagna veneta campolongo maggiore
10.000 abitanti
tre orchestre e circa mille tra bambini
e ragazzi di ogni età impegnati in
attività musicale
conosco bene questa realtà perché tutti
noi abbiamo avuto la fortuna di crescere
e di coltivare insieme le nostre
passioni
in questo ambiente educativo e musicale
d'eccezione
liberamente all'interno di un istituto
scolastico pubblico
l'istituto comprensivo diego valeri lo
spirito che anima questa realtà nata nel
2001 è quella di rendere davvero la
musica un diritto per tutti superando
ogni barriera economica sociale e
culturale
tutte queste principi ci hanno portati
ad avvicinarci ad altre realtà italiane
che condividevano i nostri stessi ideali
ed insieme a conoscere apprezzare ed
accogliere gli insegnamenti del modello
educativo e sociale ideato in venezuela
dal maestro josé antonio abreu che negli
ultimi 45 anni ha rivoluzionato il suo
paese dando una forma di riscatto
sociale attraverso l'istituzione
musicale gratuita
oggi il venezuela con tra quasi un
milione a bambini e ragazzi impegnati in
attività orchestrali ed alcuni dei
giovani musicisti provenienti da questo
progetto chiamato e il sistema oggi
suonano e dirigono nelle più grandi
orchestre al mondo
il nostro obiettivo però non è solo
quello di formare dei professionisti nel
mondo della musica
lo scopo principale è quello di
garantire ad ogni bambino la possibilità
di avvicinarsi a questa meravigliosa
forma d'arte e guadagnando un'istruzione
che fa molto oltre l'abilità strumentale
all'interno di un orchestra infatti si
imparano i valori e la gioia dello stare
insieme del condividere le emozioni
dell'impegno individuale necessario al
risultato collettivo si imparano la
costanza la perseveranza l'attenzione ma
anche la passione si parla sensibilità
la delicatezza la precisione ma anche la
creatività
si impara ad ascoltare ea rispettare
s'impara ad esprimere la propria
individualità armonizzandosi allo stesso
tempo con gli altri pensate sia
esagerato non mi credete dai proviamo tu
dici in piedi seguite quello che faccio
io
tutti insieme con me poi chi come i 234
con me come
[Musica]
da soli
frate a tutti con me limitate quello che
faccio io bravissimi ancora no
ecco
come no
corre voce bene
ecco tutto
com'è
ok
ecco
vo ce vo ce vo
vive
[Musica]
bene
ciao ciao
milly
e a
ciao
all
bambini
no no
si no
tre bravissimi fatemi un plauso
accomodatevi pure vedete non so se ve ne
siete accorti ma con questa piccola
dimostrazione
abbiamo messo in pratica la nostra
disciplina ritmica la nostra attenzione
e concentrazione e perché tutto potesse
essere efficace
vi siete ascoltati a vicenda e nessuno
ha prevaricato sugli altri
l'improvvisazione ha dato modo i ragazzi
di esprimere la loro personalità e la
loro creatività
ma perché tutto questo potesse
funzionare hanno dovuto armonizzarsi con
insieme e non ritenete voi che la
trasmissione di questi principi alla
base di una società civile debba essere
necessariamente un diritto di tutti ecco
oggi avete avuto una piccola
dimostrazione di una tra le molteplici
esperienze che l'infinito percorso
musicale vi può regalare
e la prossima volta che qualcuno vi
chiederà se avete mai suonato in un
teatro potete rispondere sì
[Applauso]